and you've been in so many movies you
must have done umpteen fights oh dear I
know when it comes down to fight scenes
I get cast as the pie eater
I did have one I got beat up by Paul
Bettany and The Da Vinci Code and it was
a moment where we were supposed to did
we rehearsed it a little bit and in
movie fights everybody treats it like
it's a real fight area you know
everybody okay are you ready I'm ready
and you know do you miss each other like
that but but Paul came rushing in and I
met him and what happened he was
supposed to knock me down against a desk
and then I landed on the ground and the
way it sounded was that's why somebody
else gets
[Laughter]
yeah Joseph Parker does you started in
the show so young at 12 so did you have
to do they always have to train you to
do all your fighting yeah but my
character was also learning so as my
character learned Island she wasn't like
amazing from the first episode she
wasn't supposed to be like you know what
she was doing so it was nice that as the
seasons went on I learned more and more
because now you're proper kick-ass like
when women fake punching each other yeah
although I'd never underestimate like
your opponent you know throw a punch
right there and I'll do it
you you sell it after the fact
[Music]
you